thank you
[Music]
foreign
if you've been following along with the
last few videos
you'll know that I found mold in my van
and extensive water damage back in June
and it was bad really bad like this all
has to go bad
I've been living in this van full time
for over four years now so I basically
lost both my home and my vehicle all at
once and I didn't really share this but
I had Loosely planned to be in Europe
All Summer Long
so this kind of threw a wrenching things
anyway I contacted my original Builder
Brett and together we formulated a plan
the timing of this whole situation was
pretty ironic because as many of you
know I've been on the fence about
whether or not I want to continue with
fan life
I'm currently in my sixth year and it's
honestly just starting to feel a little
stale and I've been caught in a state of
indecision for a while now
it's sort of like the universe said okay
you need help deciding whether or not
you're done with fan life
so here you go here's a massive problem
that is going to bring your journey to a
halt
do you want to fight for this life that
you have or choose A New Path like
putting down roots
and for me it was a gut response I
decided to get the van fixed no matter
what
[Music]
foreign
the amount of clothing alone I have 18
pairs of shoes counted these dresser
drawers here
they're just completely packed clothes
in these bags clothes stashed here
more hats
all of these bins over here are rolled
closed
laundry more stuff like this is just out
of control all my cushions and the
bedding never know when you might need a
tennis racket I have so much stuff it's
literally
outrageous look at how much toilet paper
I have
who has that much toilet paper that even
lives in a house I kind of got it
organized
stuff is stashed everywhere but like
according to department so the dresser
is full of clothes here's all clothes
all my camping gear is under the bed all
my like
maintenance car maintenance first aid
stuff is there more there backpacking
kitchen stuff
just all kinds of stuff I don't know how
long
the build is going to take so
just trying to get organized while I'm
in here just got almost everything out
of the van I have an overwhelming amount
of stuff in my life holy crap I need to
like really go through and get rid of a
lot but as you can see the van is pretty
empty I'm gonna take a few video clips
just to show you guys like why I'm doing
this change the number one reason is
because the flooring obviously got
soaked and when I ripped up some of the
flooring
it was like
not good it was not usable we pretty
much have to rip everything up these
pieces are all still really solid but
you can see that it's like starting to
crack this piece here is a little bit
loose same goes for this other side here
just pieces are starting to pull away
from the wall a little bit this here can
pretty easily be fixed with just some
caulking
but
we're actually gonna have to replace
this whole piece this whole cabinet this
will be rebuilt as well and it's going
to have a slightly Slimmer profile and
it's going to extend out a little bit I
thought about getting an induction stove
but after doing some research I just
decided that it would take way too much
power so I think I'm going to stick with
the propane these little ports here
we're going to update to USBC because
most of my appliances require USBC you
can see there's a lot of wear and tear
in this corner a lot of loose pieces I
almost always sit right here to do my
work because the table with the Lagoon
mount it just even if it's over there it
doesn't support the weight very well
you can see how warped it is right now
too oh my gosh
we're up in a high desert environment so
it's like a banana basically this
cabinet here is pretty beat up you can
see a lot of water damage down there
um the toilet drawer has really seen
better days
I had to rip out the back of this
cabinet to access the plumbing because
that's where the leak was coming from
that caused all the water damage in the
flooring so we're just going to redo all
of this we're going to redo the plumbing
we're going to rebuild this whole
cabinet you can see down here just how
dirty this is this
um the area that I cut up to with the
saw just to remove whatever wet wood
that I could but it's still I'm assuming
pretty wet under there once we get once
we lift these cabinets up you can see
back here what the wood is supposed to
look like because the water didn't quite
make it this far
but we're just gonna rip everything out
because unfortunately
it got wet
on this one solid piece and I don't want
to risk having any more wet
wood kind of covered and potentially
causing problems in the future just want
to rip everything out and have a fresh
start also I ordered a new fan
um the max fan I forget the model but
it's quieter and I'm really really
excited to replace Swap this one out
with the max fan we're thinking about
making this divider wall have a Slimmer
profile just to maximize storage space
so that I can fit a few more things back
here you guys know I have a lot of stuff
so the more storage space the better you
can see the water went all the way back
to the other side of the van because
this is where
fridges
it's like this whole subfloor is just
soaked and it's Gotta come up all right
we're starting to take stuff out
where's my fridge
whoa what's happening
the demolition
has begun as my countertop
toilet drawer
that's where the stove used to be
is the whole kitchen
cabinet
electrical I forgot to do my dishes I
don't know if I can see this I'm just
gonna remove it just go for it
here are the innards of the van so far
the cabinet with the water damage
pretty much everything is gutted at this
point at least from the bottom up
[Music]
it is empty
so wild
so many vans
[Music]
they're all completely
there we go
so here is the workstation for the van
here's a lot of the stuff from the
previous build because I've set out here
we're hoping to use as much of it as
possible we're gonna do a mahogany
subfloor which is considerably thinner
than before
I've been hoping
when you're trying to build a van but
Sunset is popping
look at that Skye
[Music]
foreign
so we just came back from bike riding
around Mary Lake in Mammoth and wow this
place is beautiful and yeah back in the
van it's starting to come along got the
cabinet counter mostly framed out same
counter mostly framed up the benches
they're a little bit bigger than before
which I'm really stoked on and all four
of these batteries is going to be a huge
upgrade really excited about that and
we're maximizing the space wherever
possible so there's going to be even
more storage in this van which I'm
really excited about other door
[Applause]
nice
[Music]
I have no idea what I'm doing
just you're doing great
you got pain rollers paint brushes
[Music]
hitting the road
bye Christy bye Christian
[Applause]
s
[Music]
let's see
all right
thank you
[Music]
Bailey hi Bailey come here
this is the supervisor hello
can I steal you
[Music]
Bailey would like to know why you're
on the roof in long sleep
in the middle of the summer yes I don't
know I officially lost my mind
we got new Cabinetry I did a little bit
of painting today we're waiting for that
to dry got the little tripod storage
area
I'm not sure if I ever told you all this
story but when I first moved out of my
apartment
camping in my car full time was just a
summer experiment after which I figured
I'd for sure get another apartment
but September rolled around and I still
wasn't sure what I wanted to do
and then
I got into what could have easily been a
fatal crash
I had just crossed the U.S Canada border
after a sunrise shoot and veered a
little too much to one side on a
three-lane highway
I caught some gravel and turned the
wheel but overcorrected and next thing I
knew the asphalt was coming straight at
my face
I rolled three times across the entire
with the highway and landed in a ditch
the door was jammed but I was able to
kick my way out and went running up to
the road thankfully no one had been
around me so I didn't hit anyone else
but at least five other cars stopped and
three of them happened to be doctors on
their way to work
someone called an ambulance which I
refused to see at first because I didn't
have health insurance
to which they replied don't worry ma'am
here in Canada it's okay we aren't gonna
charge you
by some miracle I walked away without a
single scratch
the Xterra was absolutely totaled and
the Thule rack on top had smashed to
pieces
I lost my car my home and a lot of my
stuff
I could have easily lost my life
I could have hurt someone else
but I didn't and I am and always will be
so grateful for that
and there was something else
I realized that I still wanted to live
on the road
losing it made it all very clear
so I bought another Nissan Xterra and I
recreated the same exact build and for
14 months I went on living out of my SUV
before buying this van
it's interesting and also kind of
intimidating whenever I find myself
waiting an indecision for too long
the universe has a funny way of forcing
my hand
so this is the workshop and Brett has
all these bands basically for walls
surrounding the tables
we've got more bands more vans
so many fans
I'm currently working on the Wii boost
the 110
. it is so freaking hot in here
.
we're rocking the Buns oh yeah and the
sweat smocks it's a good look
he's missing like just steam you know
oh it seriously a sauna in here it is
ridiculously hot well we got the new max
air fan going and that's definitely
helping
pray for us if you're ready
can you just push down like right here
oh that's true
what's next
[Music]
foreign
build
ings ceremony
homemade lemoncello I'm over here
I'm coming over here
[Music]
ready to go Fred's just moving her out
he's definitely gonna miss being around
all these other vans
like van Central here
can't wait to give you a full tour
she is back in
business
[Music]
foreign
which of these numbers represent a which
one is B which one is C
C is the longest of the three sides is
the hypotenuse it's across the 90 degree
angle